people of the internet's retro record
tour here and today I'm going to show
you exactly how to get Harry Potter
magic awakened up and running on your PC
even if you live in an area that doesn't
have the official PC client which if you
guys didn't know yes the game is coming
to PC in all territories eventually but
we just don't know when it's only
available in certain areas right now you
can actually download it right now in
the US I tried it the other day you can
download the official PC client however
if you try to go to your region or
server rather it's going to be locked so
right now to show you guys this is not
using the official PC client you can see
here North America and I am on the opal
I server now the way that we're doing
this is that we are running an Android
emulator and I don't want you guys to
think that this is like something Shady
or it doesn't break terms of service
it's nothing like that essentially what
you're going to be doing is enabling
your Windows PC to run other operating
systems and in this case you get to run
Android so it's not like your download
to get a bunch of free games or anything
even though this game is free to play
but if you ever wanted to play any other
Android games you can buy them just like
you normally would through the Google
Play Store using an emulator
so virtualization is just essentially
what tells your computer hey we want to
run another operating system a lot of
people use this to run Linux and in our
case we're going to be using it to run
Android so the reason that you have to
go through and change a lot of these
settings is because Windows just doesn't
enable it by default because not a lot
of people use this feature so if you
want to make sure that your system
supports virtualization you can follow
these steps right here and again I'm
going to link all of this down in the
description below so all these links
that I'm using this is actually directly
on bluestacks's help center right here
now it comes to enabling virtualization
on your system you're going to have to
enable it in two places Windows settings
and also your bio settings how to enable
BlueStacks on Windows 11 that is what I
use if you're on Windows 10 it's going
to work very similar they're just some
slight differences in the way the UI
looks so your first step is to open the
windows settings you can do this by
going down to the start menu and then
you're just going to type Windows
settings as you can see they'll do here
or you can click on the gear that works
too then Windows update
bottom left over there
and then you're going to be looking for
the advanced advanced options right
there you go ahead and click on that
then it's going to take you to the next
screen here and you scroll down until
you find recovery reset Advanced startup
go back you just click on this little
section right here
and that'll take you to this menu where
you can see Advanced startup and you're
going to hit restart now once you
restart you're going to see a different
menu so it's not going to boot into
Windows normally you're going to see
this option here and you want to click
on the troubleshoot one from there you
just click on Advanced options right
here you're going to click right here
UEFI firmware settings stay with me
trust me I promise you the first part is
by far the most difficult part once you
get through this it's smooth sailing so
then you'll go ahead restart your
machine and it's going to enter your
system bios now if you've never looked
at this screen before it can be a little
bit daunting at first and it's going to
look different based on the manufacture
of your motherboard and whether you have
an AMD or Intel CPU so because there are
so many different manufacturers your
bios is probably going to look different
than what they show in this video right
here so what I recommend is that you go
to Google type in your motherboard so I
have an MSI
b550 m
MSA motherboard
enable virtualization there it is right
there
and I mean look it took me straight to a
YouTube video that is what my BIOS looks
like so I bet that would work however if
you scroll down a little bit you can
usually find yep right there so we have
the actual MSI page so this is actually
what mine looked like right here I had
to go into overclock then Advanced CPU
configuration and it was under the one
here called svm mode I had to enable
that to get it to work properly so if
you have an Intel CPU then these are the
settings that you're going to look to
enable if you're on AMD which is what I
had then these are the settings that
you're going to look for and don't
forget make sure you save the BIOS
settings and restart now you just need
to turn on the virtual machine platform
for your Windows settings so you'll go
to start here and we search for Windows
features and you'll have one that pops
up called Turn Windows features on or
off so you can see here in step two they
say in the Windows features find virtual
machine platform and select it so mine
will already be enabled right here I
checked it earlier and then to get mine
to work there were two additional ones
that I had to enable it was Windows
hypervisor platform and also the windows
subsystem for Linux I went ahead and
checked both of those as well
so this is the app that I've been using
it's called BlueStacks there was just a
big update the other day because I know
on launch day a lot of the emulators
were not working correctly so there was
a big update to at least BlueStacks I
don't know about the others but
BlueStacks had an update and then the
game itself had an update as well so
this has been running great for me I
played a lot yesterday exclusively right
here on the PC through this emulator and
just for full disclosure here guys I am
a BlueStacks affiliate so if you use
this link right here I'll also put it in
the description as well that's really
going to go to help out the channel and
I appreciate it a lot I think BlueStacks
works great I've tried several others
even before they approached me about
this affiliate partnership and could
never get them to work properly this is
the first one that I've gotten to work
and work consistently now that being
said there are plenty of other emulators
out there so if you don't want to use
bluesacks you don't have to they've been
kind enough to sponsor this video so
that's why I'm going to be using that
for today and for the foreseeable
feature this is what I'm going to be
playing on so now that you've reached
this point you are ready to finally
download BlueStacks you can do
BlueStacks 10 or you can do BlueStacks
five both of these will work just fine
I'll link this article in the
description it does a great job of
explaining the differences between
BlueStacks 5 and BlueStacks 10 basically
BlueStacks 10 has a lot more Cloud
features so you don't actually have to
save a lot of these games to your system
so then you'll go through the steps of
installing the software in our case this
is BlueStacks just install now let it do
its thing you might have to restart a
couple of times and then you will have
to set it up with your Google account so
given that you're going to be running
Android you will need a way to sign into
the Google Play Store and download these
games
now once you finally have BlueStacks
installed on your machine it's going to
be very important that when you launch
it you right click and you choose to run
as administrator I kid you not you guys
I went through all those steps how to do
a lot of troubleshooting because I
didn't enable virtualization properly
and then it still wasn't working and I
finally found a solution that says to
make sure that you're running as
administrator and that is what finally
made everything start working so
beautifully
and then once you're in this is what the
interface looks like so you can just go
to search right here at the top and I'm
going to say Harry Potter magic awakened
I already have it installed so I'm not
sure what it'll look like here yep and
there it is right there you can also try
Hogwarts mystery or puzzles and spells
both of those work too so I hit view
details on it and already have mine
downloaded and installed so that's why
mine says play on app player here but
yours will probably say download and so
you can see here I am you know moving my
mouse and go ahead and click it responds
to The Click when I hit enter Hogwarts
here
it's going to take a second to load in
all right and here we are logging in for
the fourth straight day getting our two
keys make sure you guys do that each day
when you go in you get a little sign in
bonus but yeah just to show you once
you're in I am now using wasd to move my
character around if I want to spin the
camera around I kind of have to click
and drag
and it actually works surprisingly well
for a mobile game everything looks great
I will say the little dancing minigame
is way more difficult when you're trying
to use a mouse as opposed to just using
a touch screen so yeah good luck with
that another feature that I love is you
can actually go back and forth between
your phone and playing on PC so my phone
is Apple it is not Android so because
I've linked it to my WB account I think
that's why everything just carries over
so all my progress I was actually
playing last night in bed for a little
bit and I was using my phone to do so
now within BlueStacks you might be
annoyed at first and say oh man look at
all these ads over here but if you look
over here on the right there are all of
these additional controls all of these
settings for example that's where I can
change the volume right here so we have
it muted right now let me go ahead and
turn it back on but then this is the one
that I've been using a lot right here
it's this little toggle full screen and
when I hit that everything else goes
away all the menus all the ads again
BlueStacks is a free program so that's
why the ads are there and then you are
in the game ready to go ready to play
even have your little mouse cursor which
kind of changes over a little bit to
match the aesthetic of the game now
there are some additional on-screen
controls like over here you see was and
d and then you have C right here to type
you have q and then e for the knapsack
space will pull up your charms like that
you see I just hit spacebar I personally
don't like having that on kind of
cluttering up the UI so if you click on
this little icon right here that's a
keyboard game controls you can turn off
the on-screen controls and then you're
not going to have that cluttering up
there at the bottom so then just going
to look like this right here now if
you're on a Mac it is my hope that at
some point this game will actually be
able to run on M1 and M2 Max without
anything additional at all that's
actually a really big feature that Apple
talked a lot about when they first
started making their own chips for their
laptops again is the fact that they can
actually run iPhone and iPad apps
straight on the Mac and I actually
thought this was an automatic thing I
thought it would just work but
apparently the developers have to say
that they're okay with that they want to
enable that feature so hopefully we'll
see that at some point with magic awaken
right now though you cannot install the
game in that way on a Mac however you
can download BlueStacks for a Mac it's
going to be BlueStacks 4. they do not
have BlueStacks 5 or 10 ready yet for a
Mac but your step-by-step guide for the
Mac is much easier much simpler than it
is on Windows you can just go straight
to downloading BlueStacks for you don't
have to worry about any of the
virtualization stuff it will actually
download a DMG file on your Mac you
double click that to install then you're
going to see a screen like this you
double click that to install you'll have
to confirm here saying yes I'm sure I
want to open it then you hit install now
and you will have to verify that with
your administrator password and then
here's maybe the most important step
you're not done there because after
entering that information you're going
to get this system extension blocked
pop-up all you have to do is open up
your security and privacy as you can see
they show you here then you need to make
sure that you allow this and depending
on which version of Mac you're running
you're probably gonna have to restart
and reboot your Mac right here it says
if you're on Mac OS 10.15 Catalina or
below you can actually skip ahead to
step 12. but Big Sur or newer and you're
probably gonna need to restart now if
you try to restart and it says Hey
BlueStacks interrupted your restart just
hit cancel right here go back into that
same security and privacy menu and just
hit restart again and from there you're
good to go you're ready to launch
BlueStacks on the Mac install the app
there now I'm going to be sure to link
all of these help articles in the video
description below BlueStacks actually
has a great support page a great YouTube
page as well with a lot of these
tutorial videos that walk you through
step by step if you're stuck in a
certain process now if you guys are
actually curious about my thoughts on
the game itself then I already have a
video uploaded about that here on the
channel check it out I'll let you know
exactly what I think my honest
Impressions I'll look at here on the
right side of the screen now as always
thank you all so much for watching I'll
talk to you again soon